combien de temps encore résistera
l'aéroport de Tours la délégation de
service public sera renouvelée en
juillet pour 10 ans de plus ce
prestataire devra assurer le
développement de l'aéroport un projet
d'investissement colossal dont les
écologistes critiquent le manque de
débat on en parle avec notre invités
bonjour Christophe boulanger bonjour
vous êtes co secrétaire des
départementales du groupe Europe
Écologie Les Verts et vous êtes aussi
élu à la métropole
on sait que le trafic aérien donc va à
l'encontre de la transition écologique
l'aéroport de Tours est néanmoins assez
petit on peut penser qu'il pollue moins
qu'un grand aéroport comme Roissy et ce
qu'on peut pas envisager une tolérance
la question de la tolérance pour
pourquoi pas c'est le sujet du jour
c'est pas celui-là c'est on engage la
collectivité les collectivités qui sont
aujourd'hui partenaires sur cette
opération c'est-à-dire la Région le
Département la métropole pour une
période de 10 ans sur des bases qui sont
pas des bases saines puisque ça fait on
vient de publier aujourd'hui un rapport
à un mois de cette de cette échéance on
produit un rapport pour rappeler en fait
ce qu'est l'histoire de ces 50 60
dernières années où depuis 65 ans
précisément on nous raconte les mêmes
histoires on tergiverse on verse
d'illusions le territoire à grand coup
de de d'argent public sans aucune
avancer sur sur ce dossier et
aujourd'hui les promesses qui sont
portées par par le syndicat le smadett
sont tout aussi illusoires ont sur ces
20 dernières années sur ces 30 dernières
années il y a quatre rapports de la Cour
des comptes qui ont été produits c'est
quatre ces quatre accords de la Cour des
comptes la même chose on est sur une
absence totale de stratégie sur un
absence complète de pilotage avec une
délégation de service public qui se fait
au détriment du territoire qui au
bénéfice seul du délégataire et sans et
sans retomber économique avéré sur le
territoire il faudrait fermer cet
aéroport on dit pas qu'il faut fermer
l'aéroport on dit qu'il faut arrêter la
délégation de service public il faut
arrêter de mettre autant d'argent pour
soutenir un moyen un mode des
entreprises de transport public et
Ryanair en particulier qui sont des
entreprises qui sont des entreprises qui
ne font pas le job et qui sont pas à la
hauteur des enjeux et qui sont qui ont
été condamnés à maintes reprises pour
travailler dissimulé et pour plein plein
d'autres choses vous proposez quelle
solution alors la solution d'abord c'est
qu'on a un débat public qu'on pose un
peu les choses ça fait des années que
dans toutes ses collectivités que je
viens de citer on fait des débats à la
va-vite on s'échange quelques quelques
restes sur position on fait des débats
de 5 10 minutes alors qu'on engage la
collectivité pour 10 ans sur des sommes
colossales je le dis et contrairement à
ce qui est annoncé on va encore dépenser
plus d'argent qu'on en a dépensé dans
les années passées et ça c'est
absolument pas possible sans un vrai
débat a priori et sans que le public
soit associé au moins informé de tout ce
qui se passe
mais l'aéroport a quand même vu passer à
tour
200000 passagers en 2022 le trafic
aérien n'a jamais été aussi élevé en
France Ryanair et la compagnie la plus
rentable d'Europe la ligne tour Dublin
elle a un potentiel économique avec la
Coupe du monde de rugby est-ce que c'est
finalement ça risquerait pas de numéro
au tourisme au développement économique
du territoire alors moi on est de
factuel la Cour des comptes dit non
et j'ai plutôt tendance à croire la
plutôt la Cour des comptes que les gens
qui défendent l'aéroport sans apporter
d'éléments tangibles sans apporter
d'éléments factuels aucune enquête
aucune étude aujourd'hui ne prouve tout
ce qui est tout ce qui est avancé et
donc nous aujourd'hui on produit un
rapport pour dire ce n'est pas possible
de continuer comme ça on attend que les
pros produisent un rapport de la même
qualité pour dire que il y a des
solutions qui qui existent qui sont
défendues aujourd'hui non mais c'est à
eux dire pourquoi ils veulent maintenir
un aéroport aujourd'hui vous êtes
partisans de supprimer l'aéroport on est
partisans de ne plus subventionner les
vols les vols de longue distance tels
qui sont subventionnées aujourd'hui vous
parlez 200 000 voyageurs jours la gare
de Saint-Pierre-des-Corps c'est entre 3
millions et 4 millions de voyageurs par
an c'est des tours en jour c'est que des
des gens qui vivent sur le territoire
qui font vivre le territoire qui utilise
la gare de Saint-Pierre-des-Corps ça
fait des années que la collectivité n'a
pas mis un centime 1 euro dans ce dans
ce dans cet équipement et la porte
d'entrée du territoire ce qui fait
rayonner aujourd'hui la Touraine c'est
plutôt la gare TGV que l'aéroport de
Tours merci Christophe boulanger merci